he said you should have me on your
podcast the guy says this to me good
looking you know Middle Eastern Jewish
one of fifty thousand dollar watch and
he said you should have me on the
podcast because we can we agree on a lot
of things I'd love to kind of tell them
what's really going so why don't you
have a podcast he says oh no no I can't
have a podcast so why can't you have a
podcast he says well you know because
you know business it's gonna affect us I
said you're the problem you're the
reason why America is where it's at you
are the absolute problem so I sat there
and I said so what are you scared of he
says what do I do you know if I say
anything you know we're going to do this
and they're going to do this and they're
gonna do that that's exactly the issue
because they're sitting there saying you
know I don't want to kind of get my name
called that I'd write about you be quiet
and not say anything about it because
what if I the guy's like what my real
estate business could take a hit I said
your country could take a hit your kids
could take it you're worried about the
real estate business but then again it's
a real valid fear that a lot of people
are having nowadays but